[inaudible].
So Shannon,
I thought maybe we could begin with,
um,
how you got started on the investing journey.
Well,
my father was in the advertising business for most of his life and he
recommended to me that I buy some central airlines with some money I've made the
summer and that construction job.
So I bought 200 chairs.
I've said earlier lines at Tudor Court for,
for a $50 and a,
I met the chief executive officer whose name was Lamar mommies and uh,
he,
they cared about parents' house one time it had dinner and my mother's dog bit
his wife on the nose.
They didn't leave,
but,
uh,
anyway,
shut.
He was a good sport and resilient.
Uh,
so,
so that was starting.
How funny they were.
The stock went up.
It was acquired about a year and a half later about central airlines been bought
by frontier airlines for $14 a year.
So 2020 5 cents and turned into $14 pretty quickly.
And I think that I just thought this beats sitting out in the sun carrying
forums around and I was hooked for life and that was its success to start with.
I had a lot of failures after that,
but kind of figured it all out eventually.
Maybe I have,
I don't know,
why
did you start to invest in here?
When I bought little sidebar here,
some not by stark and was hearing something about and start getting a very good
investment system.
Cause you hear it from people that don't know what they're talking about.
We take a while to figure out who didn't know what they're talking about and who
didn't.
But uh,
you know,
I'm always fascinated by it and always interested in it.
And uh,
you know,
kid ran about myself up and my wife took me to this event every year called art
about town and you had bid on paintings and I would have been on paintings for
less than I figured the frame that it was less than the various,
the frame rail that was a value investor.
And so,
so,
uh,
they would say,
well did you make money?
Then?
I said,
no,
I never saw there was a written written down as a penny.
They're all horrible,
but they said some cheap frames.
Wow.
I think I'm somewhere in the mid seventies.
Y'All just started a banking or brokerage or more for this from Carl Snyderman
didn't Hickman and a,
I was a syndicate manager.
I did the new issues.
I don't get the new shoes and try to get the from end of the deals.
And then,
uh,
I left there and you don't want to start my own firm,
which I call row and company investment bankers,
life banker,
investment bankers,
life brokers.
Really we're just a brokerage firm.
And then the little investment banking,
but not much.
And then,
uh,
I did that and trade for the firms account.
It may a little money and then in 1985 and decided to start up fun to share the
joys,
that short selling,
which I was doing a lot of because the skyline of Dallas,
it is pure cranes like it is here now.
But,
uh,
yeah,
there was,
see through buildings everywhere and I figured something bad was gonna happen.
And so,
you know,
I started short selling
Hawaii shot selling stocks,
real estate,
well stocks and the bank stocks,
real estate stocks,
most state related stocks.
And what was the thesis that the thesis was?
It was,
it was a terribly overbuilt and there everybody was going to go broke because I
was absolutely right on.
And they did.
And,
and so,
uh,
I wouldn't say that was fun,
but it was good to be right.
The fact that I'd say my money away to the things barely broke down and made
some great buyers and she shows,
you know,
every dark cloud has a silver lining kind of deal.
So I could have done,
it doesn't matter which side you're looking at it.
Do you think getting the timing right was important with the chart settings?
Well,
of course it was.
Sure.
And,
uh,
you know,
in,
uh,
you know,
what I found though was it,
you buy stock and it goes down.
The MACI loses her mind that she put up and it goes down with some more,
you have a smaller problem and you don't worry about it.
Maybe shorter start,
he goes up,
you're just sick.
You can't even breathe because you can have remembered in Las petitions.
I mean you can die and be incapacitated and lose every dime,
every dime you have.
Uh,
there's a,
there's an overpriced stock service I took for a while,
but he's in the regulatory Microsoft and they said they ever come along and say
hope for better exit buoyant.
Well hell,
they lost all their money
so it's not a not a good solid medicine.
When I was doing it and the interest rates were high,
real rates were high and brokers call was about the prime was so have you put up
treasury bills and then short and stocky get the brokers call on the short
position,
we would mean that you'd be up 15% when he started,
we was pretty good and now course you have to pay to borrow.
So your dad when you started.
So there's a big difference there.
I didn't figure that out until later,
but that's why it was boy loves and attracting and taxes.
Also a tactic.
We're also at the same,
they're the same.
Taxes on dividends and interest in short sales and short swing province and
longterm province,
everything was taxed the same so it didn't matter.
And so that was one,
another little added factor.
Right.
Plus you really never had to cover.
You could,
you could take the nine and,
and a and a pair of the trades off,
you know me,
she put her shirt covered versus the boxers and mini bat back hold on.
Long position,
a short position,
all it 25,
six of shares and he never had to be days.
Could you explain that a little bit Chad for us?
Sure.
You could not,
you get,
uh,
you know,
you could be shorting versus a boxer,
the boxer stock,
you would borrow the shares,
the jeep and the Jeep Bosh and delivering against your short position or hold
them against your,
your position.
So you would would've covered but not recovered,
but everything be blocked out and you can just keep the tax money.
And that was outlawed in the tax roll of 1985 and that was,
that was made a little bit better business then.
So you were getting paid to bottle the taxes for a favorite book.
Yeah.
And the market was not fairly valued according
do you know,
and a lot more retail investing then,
then there was right.
Unless for years,
so not as smart.
So why did you give up shots selling?
Well,
it becomes all consuming.
You know,
you,
you're,
you take,
if you feel better about it as you get older,
but it hurts worse.
And,
uh,
my mother kind of typically,
you know,
we're just trying to always trying to be optimistic about things.
And she said,
well,
no,
she said the no worry,
I'm sure something terrible happened.
The only met her.
But
that was sort of the idea.
You know,
you're looking for bad outcomes all the time,
which a happier life if you're looking for good outcomes.
Right.
And so after you get up shots selling,
um,
you moved on to finding small local companies in Texas.
Can you talk to us a bit about that?
Well,
actually in the,
in the time that,
uh,
Korean airlines,
I also own small company there turnarounds when they hit three and then four
airplanes.
So I miss him about the airline,
doesn't listen and they something in about advertising this a little bit bigger
than my father.
And so I was sort of set up on some things on those lines and,
and uh,
I found that one kind of door leads to another and everything's kind of
connected.
We're all connected.
And so between my father,
and you have much more friendly toward now than it was,
where's the lie unfortunately.
But,
uh,
you could kind of get a feel for different businesses.
So,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the shorts would eventually turn into lungs that I bought back.
It was short deputy big group in 1991 and then covered 19 and Kevin [inaudible]
91 and then you end up buying it and a lot on it,
uh,
in southwestern Ontario.
Very well On.
So when did you buy your first chairs of [inaudible]?
1974.
The baton is bottom of mine.
I still have them.
You still have the same?
Oh,
no,
no.
Understand.
Years.
I sold most of it,
but the stuff is very valuable.
Uh,
would you know,
uh,
how,
how much the revenues have compounded by a stock price is competitive base into
bought it.
I always probably 27% of it he age 20% of it.
30 plus.
This is amazing,
but what,
what was it about southwest that got your attention?
Armies.
He's the same guy that was a hint of central airlines.
Right?
And so I felt like I knew him then and uh,
it was obvious to me that they were doing something better,
faster,
cheaper.
They were flying between Dallas and San Antonio and Houston on a tight schedule
and doing it for not much more than the price of a bus ticket to the traffic was
expanding.
They were stimulated the market and it's growing.
And they did that everywhere.
They went all over the United States and now they're gone abroad.
You know,
it's a,
it's a better story.
They have one airplane that they fly.
It is through an engine out that's on,
it's on the news indictment.
It was a
once in a lifetime kind of deal and did an airline.
It's very needle because there's only really in there Joan loss and all these
years there he runs,
went broke all the time,
but they didn't put their customers first.
They put themselves first.
That's [inaudible] and their employees,
they treat everybody well right around 15 years ago maybe or a little older than
that.
Um,
you change their outlook.
Again,
focusing on companies that can scale new things faster,
better,
cheaper for the customers.
Yeah.
How did this change happen?
And maybe give us some examples.
Well,
partner,
you know,
kind of an
odd man out kind of failure.
You know,
it'd be owner stock in a company,
you're kind of a second
right?
Compared to the management.
You know,
you don't,
they don't always tell you the truth and they're manipulated a year.
But if you think the company's really doing something for the stakeholders,
for the shareholders,
for the customers and for themselves,
you feel a lot better about it.
So yeah,
you feel,
I'd feel better than the mystery of I've invested in a company like that and a
so better,
faster,
cheaper,
and for and not to the customer.
And to the delight of the customer and a B on a scale,
then if it works in another thing that advertising,
I did,
I did this WPP group,
I told you about work.
Martin Sorrell just left.
He got fired.
But he said that word globalization is a misnomer.
That the better word is Americanization.
People all over the world really want to live the way we do here.
I know you believe that there's something to it.
And uh,
so this is a success here.
It can be a success elsewhere.
And that's certainly been the case of airlines have been this Starbucks.
It's,
uh,
you know,
Amazon,
all of these companies operate throughout the world and you know,
he's talking about the law of large numbers.
Well,
how you need to own a stock that has a large number because there are a large
number of people in the world in large number of
square miles to cover,
and you got to get out there before someone beats you to it.
I think these big companies have he age and age now,
and then they can cumbersome opes like they used to be.
Uh,
they're,
they're really big and strong and powerful and they just win,
win,
win.
Right.
So following up on that chat recently,
I think you wrote about,
um,
the necessity of large numbers,
not that large numbers and not just needed to compete but actually succeeded.
Right,
right.
Um,
so can you talk to us a little bit about that?
Why do you think large numbers are a necessity?
And maybe give us an example of a company that you think as efficiency going for
it.
He talking about Google came,
we,
uh,
well all of them really,
you know,
southwest airlines downs is going to Mexico and they're going to the Caribbean,
they're big enough to do it.
And uh,
no would sit aside and that southwest do to them what they did.
I wouldn't say that much and it can happen again.
People are just smarter.
And I think that,
I think that the board compositions have changed.
I think that they were,
are more attentive and,
and the kind of doll,
and I have seen how the chief executive officer,
he sits there and acts like a dictator there over and women on the boards of
health I think.
And uh,
there's just more visibility.
It's hard to be off a bit secretive as people used to be.
Right.
I think that governance is better and I think opportunities are better perceived
and investors aren't any smarter.
And uh,
but I think that,
you know,
the whole situation has improved
you.
This stress from efficiency,
a shadow,
any,
any say it like Costco is not just efficient but elegant.
Oh Man.
It's great.
It's fun to be there.
Fun to shop there.
You save money,
you get great products,
you get great value.
See the same people there.
And uh,
I think it's,
I think the shopping is a little bit of an adventure and Jen fun and they put
things in the store and this is going to get you back.
How did you approach Costco as an investment decision?
Did you uh,
well I liked going there as is probably simple as that.
And thrive.
I like it.
Other people probably like it and they do.
Okay.
Uh,
you want to say money or get good daddy.
You don't care about the brand name?
I mean the,
the uh,
right over the kindle one is it,
it's a great,
great style that Caitlyn
and uh,
what I'm losing my mind here,
but yeah,
it's got everything.
Like everything that,
uh,
one time I ended,
it wasn't his investment group and,
and um,
the deal on the dinner we're going to was the person we had the worst bottle of
wine had to buy dinner.
And so I went and I could take a bottle of wine that my wife had picked out from
constellation brands.
I can't remember the name of it,
but it was a 92 on the monitor board or something.
And,
uh,
they way I heard the waitress complaining this one is flawed,
the court has no gun and,
and uh,
and they didn't put it,
he didn't wrap it up.
And Mr Kin folks,
and I know what it is that I can give up is me,
I'll buy dinner.
Then I wrote a letter to Jim Sinegal.
I'd had this horrible experience and,
and uh,
the Galley,
they doctor constellation brands in there against her did again for,
uh,
concert giving me my money back.
Uh,
you know,
I just made a huge profit on it and,
uh,
bought more stock and I did the same thing to Mcdonald's and talking about
something terrible that happened there.
And I got a form letter back,
sorry for your bad experience.
And then there's nothing,
but you know,
that sort of heroic responses is going over overboard,
bending over backwards to make people happy.
And it's a,
and the customer comes first.
You get ahead and then you go even behind.
So I think,
um,
but when you said customer comes first,
I'm reminded of another,
you know,
another one.
If you're nice characterizations about stage one,
companies teach two companies and stage three companies.
And these aren't to do with size of the company or age of the company.
They are with how the company custom stage one,
everything's new.
You're doing something better,
faster,
cheaper for the customer.
Your stock is soaring.
Can you give us examples of each stage?
Well,
uh,
any,
any little company that takes off southwest airlines has been,
he's going to stage one the whole career.
And uh,
stage two is maybe like got Starbucks where they start selling tea and,
and different food and trying to mix up the,
trying to get more money from the same person.
Okay.
And a stage three is most airlines and banks and everything else where there's
no question they're out to get you.
So how do you detect this date?
This change between stage two and stage three?
Shy a customer.
So I gave her,
it was obvious,
isn't it?
That's what I think.
So what are the hallmarks?
Shadow for great business like me?
Stage two,
stage one kind of business.
What are the hot,
well,
I would love to find a business.
It was basically better,
faster,
cheaper.
Okay.
On a scale that can be taken globally,
that I'd seen it work in the United States,
the great management,
you know,
I don't know how you'd define that,
but you know what we see it and uh,
some valuation that was,
you know,
somehow you could think it was reasonable and uh,
know it sounded like that.
I was laughing the other day about that.
Uh,
David Allan Coe song,
you know,
the,
I think your song is perfect,
but you haven't said anything about Mama or trains or being drunk or falling off
the bus or you know,
but there's all the ingredients are there for perfectly,
just like the upgrades are there for perfect stock and you're always looking for
the perfect stock.
Do you do focus on capital intensity at all?
When you look at a paint company and Evelyn intensive,
we have one capital intensiveness how they use their balance sheet.
Is that those things you look at?
Well,
I look at it,
but I,
I presume they know more than 90 days.
I don't,
I'm not too judgmental about.
Okay.
So let's invert that a little bit.
You know,
like college,
Jacobi and Charlie Manga.
So what are some things you want to widen the business?
Well,
if you were still [inaudible],
you know,
he was not doing something better,
faster,
cheaper and things have been worth,
it irritates people.
Okay.
They don't lock it in.
Business is going down and uh,
it has no point in potential overseas because it has no potential,
potentially the United States.
And it was just,
it'd be perfect inversion.
I either industries or sectors that you would have wide,
well,
I don't think that way.
I think the ones that I would be attracted to you.
Okay.
Uh,
and clearly,
uh,
technology that homegrown is kind of interesting because all the money I was
living at home and the parents are getting tired of them and I think they'll buy
houses at some point.
Technology and homework,
home building sector.
You kind of the whole modern home yoga,
the smart home.
Right.
And uh,
yeah,
so I don't know,
this guy that runs up runs up a Pulte political with yes.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
I don't think it matters too much,
but they're all going to have it.
We're the technology finally brought in the house to bring the mass into the
modern age.
If I can continue on,
you know,
one of another Charlie monger is uh,
um,
we learned more from my mistakes then for my successes.
I don't know a lot then.
So after shots selling,
we know once you move to being along and be consumer focused investor,
what are one or two mistakes you've made that you want to talk?
I don't want to tell her about it.
And the smaller companies I have,
uh,
there was a company that was called employer's casualty insurance company that
Worker's compensation is a cheap,
cheap stock and then always been a great company and had a great balance sheet
and the manager wouldn't talk to me and I presented them meant that was so good.
They didn't want to share the information.
And so,
uh,
I bought it and they wouldn't return the phone call and went broke.
Um,
that's a bad example,
a good example of that.
Another one,
you know,
it had some success with southwest airlines several times.
And,
uh,
I got very,
she'd Greyhound buses and even my wife said,
what are you thinking about?
You know,
no one rides a bus and,
and,
uh,
you can see that no one was on the bus because the windows are tinted,
so that,
that was a painful one.
Um,
so you probably picked up a lot of trading techniques as a short seller,
looking at price,
volume,
maybe margin calls,
technical.
Um,
no,
I didn't learn anything.
So do you look at anything other than the customer experience and fundamentals
and you invest in a business?
Well,
it's nice if,
if a stock is off for the wrong reason,
okay,
that's always a good one.
Um,
they're panicked about something.
They shouldn't,
this your honors or panic numbers and they shouldn't be panicked over.
That's a good reason to do it.
You got a better,
better,
you get a better bargain that way.
But I think in the long term it doesn't make that much difference when you buy
it and you buy the right company.
So let's focus on that a little bit.
Um,
the valuation date,
how do you approach valuation or setting five,
eight business?
Um,
what is an upper bound you're willing to pay?
How do you like about that?
I'd want to see how you can pay 10 times what she thought it was initially can
earn and be okay with me.
Uh,
if you had a pretty high degree of competence in it,
because with interest rates where they are and you've got to compete,
think what you're going to do with your money.
And if people say,
well,
mark,
very overpriced and the Nasdaq sales at 33 times earnings or whatever it sells
at,
well,
you know,
what's the yield on a 10 year government?
3%,
that's 33 times earnings and that's the most they're going to earn.
Yup.
So the companies have a chance to earn a lot more as I think stocks starts
probably cheap route your choices of what you can do.
The money real estate in any matters.
Uh,
farming one,
I don't know what you're gonna do.
Your choices are limited.
You know,
stock is its people.
It's real estate,
it's capital,
it's machines,
it's put together by smart people and working in creating value and growling.
Pretty exciting.
And then exactly all very much now,
but it will end and then thought it through.
So once you buy a stock,
ideally you never want to sell it.
You're,
you're right.
You know very well that I'm selling creates two problems,
right?
Um,
the,
the tax problem and the property pay taxes,
then you've got to replace the investment,
right.
You to be right twice,
Are going to do it on a real growth.
So are going to be right once so,
but sometimes you still have to set and sure.
And uh,
do,
do you sell because the situation changes or do you sell also sometimes because
the price runs up too much.
How do you think I've done a little bit of that.
Uh,
you know,
there's a WPP group,
which I bought years ago.
I sold some in 2001,
so it's not going to crazy price and then get it all sold.
But I kept it and then,
uh,
you know,
I knew Martin Sorrell and watched him,
but then I watch other companies come along like,
like,
you know,
this one and you know,
it was hurting their business very badly,
so I eventually sold it and made a good sales too.
Uh,
that would be a reason,
you know,
the bit is fundamentally changed by technology
or by something that they haven't done.
That would be the reason to sell it or the management's banners.
There's something changed that,
you know,
you could see,
but not because it didn't show relative strength or something crazy like that.
Shad.
If again,
shift gears a little bit.
Um,
you've spoken about the need for pension funds to,
to,
to be simple and investing process.
And recently there have been incidents of funds that have invested in,
uh,
exotic foreign agriculture and things that didn't work out well.
Why do you think this happens?
Um,
and what can be done to improve this?
Yeah,
you'll think of yourself as a star.
I think it helps,
you know,
you have more money coming in and going out.
Hopefully you're already near to buy stocks and your estate grows and you get a
better job,
or you don't get a better job,
but you were spending more sagging mess and you're saving and you grow up in and
you're going to be rich,
old guy or girl or whatever.
And uh,
that's the way it works.
And these patient funds have more money going out than coming in and compound
interest is the eighth wonder of the world.
But when it's working against you,
you can't beat it.
That's what's happening in these pension funds are I promise more than they can
deliver.
And so they're there,
you know,
saying they're making money or they're only 75% funded or something like that,
but really they're going to go broke.
And,
uh,
you can be an alarmist about it.
And yet I got fired as I was the chairman of the Texas pitching to be board for
12 years or something.
And,
uh,
you know,
the Governor Perry finally fire me to get there and I don't listen to tire near
me.
But,
uh,
your compound interest is,
is a wonderful thing to have on your side in a terrible thing to have worked
against you.
Do you think that's likely to change in the coming years?
Do we?
Oh,
sure,
sure.
I don't change like silicon up in the west or the east or wherever it doesn't.
And you know,
they're immutable laws.
I'm going to change their behavior isn't gonna Change.
People get hold of other people's money.
They like it,
it gives him power and they want to be smart.
So she had one of the books I think that has really influenced you has been the
money masters by John Train.
Yeah.
What about the book influenced you?
Um,
and are there,
well,
he's a good money manager and,
and uh,
he understood the distinction is that investors were making their minds.
It's just a good survey and nothing's changed.
It's in.
No one had ever studied investment managers before.
They were just kind of like clerks or something in the became kind of,
kind of a margin than my sometimes,
and it became interesting to people.
But the thing I found interesting.
Yeah,
he's very thoughtful.
And one time I said,
uh,
after standing on these people,
now you investors and all this,
how did you become a growth stock manager?
Like t Rowe price?
And he said that uh,
value investors are really kind of glorified accountants.
They're looking at the gap between their perceived value of what the assets are
going to be worth in its market capitalization and trying to close the
difference.
And then they did,
they got to go buy something else.
So it's a constant turnover process.
Have you ever make a mistake?
You'd pay a lot of taxes and you've lost all your money,
but a growth stock investor,
which he said,
he said that suited his nature.
He really kind of a futurologist and I'm looking at the future and trying to
figure out what's going to happen.
He said that suited his nature.
So that's what he did.
And that makes perfect sense to me.
He didn't requires fewer people.
And he said to me,
write a couple of times in your life,
a lot of your colleagues,
um,
you,
you spoke about the spectrum of investors shots at,
as activists,
investors.
Do you want to share that?
I was just saying that,
that,
uh,
the short sellers really think they're the smartest people on earth.
They're much smarter than these managements.
And,
and uh,
there's this Martin their risk,
their whole to stash to improve the ride and they are going to broker,
have nervous breakdowns sheet themselves a minute.
I had a good friend who's killed him tell her,
but,
um,
it's terrible lie.
And then the next ones are the uh,
or activists,
investors,
activists.
They think they're smarter than Management Day.
They're going to tell them how to do it.
And,
uh,
so they,
they just didn't get in there and start saying,
do this,
do that,
and we want to sell the company and we'll make these fees and,
and then,
uh,
the value and the value investors I've already talked about.
But,
um,
and you can rank them all and then the growth stock and Mr just think this
company is smarter than I am.
They know the business better than I need.
Plus it's a great business and then now get out of it.
And that's how you have a slightly days there.
You want to put yourself on the side where you have an advantage where and they
don't.
So if you perceive that there was a long term teacher for the business,
they're doing something better,
faster,
cheaper,
and for the customer you can buy it at a reasonable price.
And,
uh,
and if you're wrong,
you can sell it.
That's a pretty good deal.
And,
uh,
and that's when one of the things I want to take a chat.
Yes.
I want to get a little personal with this question for you.
So two decades ago you were diagnosed with Parkinson's.
Yeah.
Shortly after which you consider checking on your phone.
Um,
but then you chose not to shut it down.
Maybe you should walk us through that.
Uh,
and also after that you've stated that having Parkinson's has actually made you
a better person.
Can you talk with Michael J.
Fox,
I'm on his board.
He calls up.
Barnes is a gift that keeps on taking,
but I think it makes you a little humble and a more appreciative of what you did
have going ride.
It would make adjustments to it.
But,
uh,
my first reaction was what the hell is going on here?
And I thought,
well,
I'll do everybody a favor and shut the fund down.
And I gave a lot of the money back.
I had some stocks that were hard to get out of their illiquid and dragged my
feet.
And then this is what we also am I going to do.
So my mind in a very good record ever since,
but I had a good record the whole time.
But,
but uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
changed your life a little bit and uh,
you appreciate the things that go your way and things that no you don't worry as
much about was written to Sam.
Uh,
completely pleasant personality is not.
And uh,
uh,
but you know,
I think investing is a matter of finding out who you are and where you fit in
the world.
And had all fits together,
you know,
I don't know who's saying it is,
but you don't know who you are and they start going to an expensive place to
find out,
uh,
is true,
but it'd be fit your nature with your investment style and it makes economic
sense and probably do pretty well.
And you think of yourself as a stock where you have more coming in than going
out.
And so you did something with the money.
In other words,
you're managing your cash flow,
you're going them in a rich old guy or girl or whatever.
And um,
that makes sense to me.
So I feel like I've got the,
the game is going my way and I feel like that's the way anybody who thought
about it shouldn't go.
And he was in the television,
the stocks under accumulation,
it's bringing out,
it's breaking down,
its lacking support.
I'm selling,
I sell,
buy,
sell,
sell his,
pay a lot of commissions and,
and a dealer spreads and lose your money and talk more.
So Chad,
before we,
you know,
we open it up to the audience for questions.
I want to ask you one question that we ask all our guests.
Um,
what is some advice you would give the personal investor,
someone who starting their journey today,
maybe investing their first few dollars and trying to make compounding work for
them?
The same thing.
Just who are you,
what do you like,
you know,
your a cheerleader
Buer yeah,
you went to home team and where you want the home team to lose and take as many
as you like.
You liked the management,
you think they have a bright future,
you like dealing with them,
they're good people and just said it,
said I and own it.
And think of yourself as a partial owner of a business just like you're the
owner of your entire business,
which is your life.
So that's kind of more above at one on one and combined with a little pop
psychology and my experience and that's what I would do and that's what I'm
trying to do.
That make sense?
No,
thank you sir.
Thank you so much.
Fun being here.
I think we'll open it up to audience questions and,
uh,
I have a few more in case we have time at the end of the bargain.
I thank you for your talk.
A that's very,
very inspiring.
So I have question about the large number is a necessity.
I was wondering if you think there's a,
uh,
the risk of,
you know,
the Anticosti once the company goes large,
like the large member goes terrifying aspect of it.
Easily,
easily
the litigation starts coming when they're trying to use the government to
protect themselves from competition or something.
So I don't know,
it'll be interesting.
You know,
I,
I watched,
uh,
than other companies other day talking on television about,
about its issues and problems,
but I think that they did these congressmen and these latest or state
legislators or they're so busy,
they don't have to have to understand anything very clearly.
And uh,
you know,
the business is still good.
It will probably survive and do fine.
And they have the elderly,
they have constituencies that people vote.
And,
uh,
so I don't,
I don't worry about it too much and worry about it some,
but not too much.
It's overrated and that does make sense.
That answers your question.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
Next,
you talked about better,
faster,
cheaper,
what is one business that better,
faster,
cheaper,
that you would like to own,
but you don't because of price or whatever other reason.
And I have a second part.
Yeah.
What is something that you owned in the past that is no longer better,
faster,
cheaper and why?
Yeah.
Or dolls and then they're getting beaten by lots of people now and a
Petsmart,
which started selling very expensive products.
So you saved money but your dog up warehouse doors and build them down and then
more functions in them.
But it was not,
he's got a company with I can do to the dog or new to you or how did it get
tricky?
And,
um,
but really I'm just trying to find the ones that are good and I hold him.
I saw him,
WPP,
which I don't know what I mean.
33 times on a million.
Uh,
the reason was,
was it the competitors on argued bedrooms,
we're doing it better,
faster,
cheaper,
and getting more for the money.
And who you watch,
you watch regular television now and the ads aren't for drugs that,
you know,
the side effects might be that you'll die and crying for your mother.
Uh,
they're just terrible off pudding.
and so on the ad that applies to you directly,
did you,
and you only see it's so structured,
didn't tell you somethings you want to hear him.
It seems like a better deal to me.
I think I'd also written about Carmax,
which,
which back in the day was excellent pricing.
Right.
But with discoverability now,
yeah,
the advantage is gone.
Uh,
because everybody knows what everybody paid for everything because of the
Internet.
Yeah.
One last question.
Um,
we had Mr Schwab visit us,
I think about two years ago from Charles Schwab and he talked about how,
in his words,
a Charles Schwab continues to deliver their services to their customers better,
faster,
cheaper.
How do you think about Charles Bob say,
compared to the CTO,
which you
[inaudible] heard of Tito?
Yeah,
I got a good price on or I'm ready to get out of it.
But
do you think Charles Schwab does better,
faster,
cheaper?
You are in that industry,
so probably you know better about who does.
I think that right now the Thoreau prize probably knows better because their
personal growth companies and the Margaret and paying the premium that is
certainly capable of paying for those companies.
You know,
I can remember I was not in the market at that time,
the nifty 50,
you know,
or in duplicable companies that would always be in portfolios regardless and
always grown to now something a hundred times earnings I 1973.
So I think that sort of thing could happen again.
And we have a world 50 world nifty 50,
we're,
you know,
you don't buy bitcoin woman.
Hell,
Coca Cola stock used to be like bitcoin
or the technology companies are like that.
Uh,
I think that could easily happen.
And I think that,
that these companies can make the,
you know,
they know more about other businesses and I do.
And they can buy them for stock or bond for cash.
Everybody turns into a Warren Buffett,
Ghana,
we,
what do we learn from Warren Buffett?
I mean,
yeah,
he started out with no sound,
you know,
delivering papers and turn that into be the richest guy in the world for a
while.
And,
uh,
what did he do?
He just had an obsession with money and,
and,
um,
there were spinning and this compound and compound and compound it,
uh,
Aldi's wonder about nonprofit investments.
Um,
and when I think of buffet dot Kates and lots of lots of tech investments,
um,
you know,
is it in the context of philanthrophy versus giving the way,
what's his actual investment and being able to manage it.
And I always wonder what the thought process is when the rich decide to go one
way or the other.
And I'm just curious to hear your thoughts.
Honor,
accumulating money,
um,
uh,
philanthrophy or,
you know,
investment and change in the context of larger good.
Uh,
how do,
how do investors think about it?
Not all the time.
And I don't,
I don't know.
Sometimes I'll,
I'm usually really disappointed by what I discovered about what was really
happening.
I mean,
you know,
people get old and they won't have hospital's named after and they want to
invest in healthcare and the healthcare people are just charging more every year
and it's become too big a burden.
Uh,
not to complain about it,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I think it's an issue,
you know,
die.
We all your money and uh,
you'd rather have,
you do decide what I'm do with it and then that someone else decide what to do
with it certainly turned anyone's going to be better than the government
probably.
I think it was a big issue.
We don't live forever is we all think we will.
Yes ma'am.
Hi.
Ah,
I wonder,
what's your advice about the risk controlling for prison?
Any writers don't have much time to investigate what's going on in your market.
Well,
you'd beat 99% of investors if you just bought this and p 500 index from
vanguard or fidelity or something like that for most people ought to do and they
wouldn't worry about the individual dies or no,
you put 90% of your money in those index funds and,
and then uh,
play with the other money.
Just saw your play money and have fun with it.
That'd be my advice.
I really enjoy your sort of a three stage model and how companies sort of get
fat and they get lazy and then you know,
get eaten.
Yeah.
One question I have is,
you know,
how frequently the companies that you've purchased,
turn into a different stage.
Are you obviously you're trying to buy ones that always stay in stage one and
end up in Stage two but are successful in stage one that leads to problems.
It's like when people,
it's just like exactly like a person
and uh,
you know,
at some point,
I mean,
you know,
the company is successful and it wants to do something else and then visuals do
something else that didn't make it money in the first place.
And this is exactly the same thing.
So you want to have,
make enough money so that you're comfortable when you get your needs taken care
of.
But that's a nap probably unless it becomes a game or an obsession.
Uh,
when you're right,
exactly.
It's the same thing as it were a person.
Can I ask a brief followup,
which is in,
in um,
a profile of you from 2016.
You mentioned that you aim to have about 15 stocks in your portfolio at any
given time and you sort of sell off the worst performing one every year and try
to replace it.
And that,
incidentally,
you also mentioned that by concentration only about six of the make up about 70%
of the actual portfolio by value.
Is that a fairly constant sort of performance metrics or is it,
what happened is this is what happened to me,
but I liked it.
Not,
I'm probably about 12 or 13 stocks and most of them are most of the money then
very few stocks.
But um,
you want to be diversified to the point that you got the odds in your favor,
but not to the point that you don't keep up with them.
And
I'm being a little bit more disciplined about it now.
I used to be,
but you know,
it's hard to sell stock in.
Once you have a profit in it,
it's hard to sell it,
pay the taxes,
make up the net worth and bedding dealer spread and make the money back.
So we tend to do some mega companies at low cost,
but you know,
if you want to step out,
you got to sell them
and they got to fit.
Would you really think is happening?
I mean I don't,
I was saying the same thing 10 years ago,
but my portfolio is completely turned over since then.
And uh,
the reason is I have better companies now.
I think,
knock on wood,
as companies grow,
the culture is very difficult to maintain.
Right.
Especially when bureaucracy creeps him.
What made you believe that southwest will continue?
Uh,
it's called continue keeping its culture in future.
It's culture.
Yeah.
Well,
they've got a good guy,
Gary Keller who was running it and they've always had good chief executive
officers,
but it's,
uh,
it's hard to change a culture.
It's hard to change it for the worse,
aren't changed for the better.
And uh,
you know,
I like to pick on American Airlines,
but it just seems like they invariably do the exact thing that I would've done.
One,
no one would do nine,
changing a reservation.
Southwest,
they let you change them,
change your time.
Marine Airlines,
you have to pay,
buy another ticket.
By the time they tag their penalties and everything else on you.
It was stupid.
I don't understand it.
And uh,
yeah.
So who is your,
is your fidelity to dude's,
to your customer.
And in the shareholders,
you know,
you've got stakeholders in any business and you got to treat him Ryan and uh,
a lot of the times he's professional management to get hold of these companies
and they think they're the ones to be served that need to serve themselves
first.
And everybody can see that and they react against it and they don't share in the
business and they don't,
they would go on,
which is fine.
I guess they made it makes plenty of money,
but he could have made more and had more fun and contributing to society rather
than
not.
If I may ask another question,
uh,
I understand,
for a short seller is hard also because of you not only need to carry your cc's,
right and you also need to get your timing right at a value investor.
You know,
I guess you're not supposed to time the market and we know it's very hard,
but I keep wondering because uh,
uh,
for example,
right now we are in a late cycle,
a day part of the cycle.
I wonder being understand now we should not timing the market one or if there is
a strategy you will sink a,
you know,
a new master would too slightly differently then,
the beginning of the cycle.
I don't know,
it's kind of a
right.
Another word.
Is the cycle found that out from you?
I don't know that we are now.
Uh,
I don't have any idea.
I think that that a time I've been in the business people,
general public's attitude is much less interested in the stock Morgan and uh,
there are fewer shares or fewer companies that are public.
There are,
uh,
there are better companies now.
They're better run and a is just as competitive,
but they make more money.
The profit abilities are,
and I think stocks are a heck of a deal.
Run it what else you can do with your money and a few of those other things.
Right.
You know,
the better,
faster,
cheaper,
and for the customer and uh,
the light of the customer and wars,
the United States,
it can be taken internationally.
I don't see how you miss when you find him.
I hope you'll call me and tell me about it.
I think,
uh,
I think we're out of time.
Oh,
gets so much ad for speaking with us.
I think we should all.